bon voila un petit peu
voilà et
l'a eu voilà je sais pas si vous voyez
bien sûr un sur un ordinateur alors
c'est c'est quoi ces images vous aimez
c'est parce qu'il pensait ne pas être
filmé c'est c'est quoi cette histoire de
drogue un petit peu dans les télé
réalité vous qu'ils avaient quasiment
toute cette zone est et 4
way différentes productions wii donc je
peux témoigner des différents problèmes
qu'il ya dans les productions alors
c'est quoi
dans les anges il ya de la drogue ça
c'est un fait c'est sûr et avéré le
problème c'est quoi c'est qu'à l'heure
actuelle les candidats qui prennent de
la drogue ont des comportements du coup
bas qui sont agressifs de par les
conséquences de la drogue qui prennent
ou avocat dacquois ils sont en manque de
drogue ont du coup on a aussi les
répercussions de ce manque de drogue sur
nous les candidats c'est à dire que moi
lorsque j'ai fait l'expérience des ans
j'avais 19 ans à ce moment là j'étais
tout jeune je me suis dit bon ça va être
cool ça va être un peu des vacances
comme tout le monde pense on faisait ça
va être des vacances avec génial
d'arriver ça peut changer ta vie est en
fait je me rends compte que je dans un
milieu où déjà les anciens qui sont là
depuis maintenant de nombreuses années
dans la téléréalité ont plus
de facilité que nous appellerons pas les
mêmes mais quand vous dites qu'il ya
donc vous l'avez vu vous oui j'ai vu les
cordes d'apprendre à draguer j'ai
surtout vu un membre de la production
arrive est littéralement défoncé dans un
moment de crise on avait nos besoins
offre donc c'était pas filmé on avait
besoin à ce moment là d'un encadrement
parce que la situation était devenue
violente physiquement et lui est arrivé
en voulant nous aider mais encore plus
défoncée donc du coup comment on fait si
en fait les candidats witt amandois
production c'est pardon c'est un petit
assistant de prononcer un producteur
c'est pas la même chose c'est un
producteur qui m'a demandeurs s'est
arrêtée ce que j'ai parlé avec lui
récemment qui a arrêté donc de
travailler avec ta production des anges
qui s'est mué dans quelque chose de
complètement différent et qui lui-même
avoue que c'était extrêmement malsain et
que et que surtout balle n'était pas
apte à de me protéger vous même la
quantité des autres
hugo debora je me permets pas en fait
c'est fou parce que tout ce que tu dis
en fait moi j'ai participé donc un
tournage aussi de télé réalité aux
vacances des anges les saignements et en
fait je savais pas c'est à dire et moi
j'ai préparé un petit peu juste que
j'étais en fait tu dis presque la même
chose que ce que j'allais dire je suis
obligé d'être honnête c'est à dire non
moi j'ai pas vu de drogue là par contre
la production est à la recherche de
séquences les gros caractères de
l'émission donne tous les petits
caractères sous vous il ya aucun suivi
psychologique il ya une ambiance qui est
vraiment très particulière et c'est en
fait la priorité c'est vraiment avoir
des séquences il ya une violence même
hors caméra moi qui m'a subjugué obligé
d pas candidat j'étais observateur je
venais intervenir et honnêtement son
témoignage je ne peux que adhérer parce
que j'aurais dit la même chose en fait
été par un mémo ses parts dans jal y
mélange pendant plusieurs années oui à
voir des séquences oui oui poussé pour
qui les séquences oui mais du coup je te
donne la parole aux cimes et moi et je
le jure ce que j'ai pu faire je n'en
n'ai jamais ou alors j'étais débit mais
personne n'a jamais vu ça j'ai pas plus
de bruit et sur l'australie sur
l'australie est ton avis avec les
candidats aux appels sur des lancements
qui passerait de tournage après dans des
chambres avec eux sur les lancements
j'étais là et je voudrais que les
comportements par exemple qui
remplissent pas seulement à la saison 8
saisons humides où je pense que vous
avez travaillé avec aurélie preston
cavic non j'étais petit j'étais plus
large et et j'avais déjà été virés pas
j'étais parti
magali satuc pardon on va être très
honnête tu le découvres pas tu dis oui
c'est vrai mais moi je ne peux pas
remettre aujourd'hui en question ce que
tu dis en vrai je n'étais pas avec toi
donc si tu dis que tu l'as vu je vais
pas te dire tu es une menteuse excès
passés loin de la meute en appelle
d'autres y chante depuis la villa
d'accueil de tous dans les anges - les
ans je n'y suis jamais allé en temps moi
j'ai fait j'ai animé une émission qui
s'appelle les princes et les princesses
de l'amour ce sens quatre ans voilà
pendant quatre ans je n'ai jamais vu de
drogue donc c'est difficile pour moi
d'arriver et de dire il ya de la drogue
parce que moi même j'en ai jamais vu
dans la production avec qui je
travaillais d'accord je peux pas accuser
tu vois ce que j'ai à dire sauver mais
je pense que tu dis c'est que admettons
allez la dent ne se prendra pas sur les
tournages à partir du moment où on prend
des candidats qui à l'extérieur des
tournages se droguent l'effet de les
faire revenir sur des tournages en
sachant qu'ils sont en manque de drogue
et que par conséquent leur comportement
va changer en étant beaucoup plus
irritables beaucoup plus agressif c'est
très dangereux pour les autres quand ils
qui leur en donne sur le tournage ce qui
le rend dogues aucun des valeurs qui
leur en donne je suis pas avec les ont
vus que je prends pas de drogue donc je
peux pas savoir qui sont leurs noms mais
moi j'ai parlé avec certains candidats
et et j'ai entendu tout comme toi que y
avait effectivement des candidats qui
ont réussi des fois en trouver pendant
des joueurs mais ça n'avait rien à voir
avec la production c'est à dire qu'en
fait et au contraire moi de ce que je
sais et de ce que je me suis renseigné
les productions si elle sait ce qu'elle
doit faire attention à vienne te vois en
train de te droguer tu sors
immédiatement c'est l'exclusion
immédiate ça c'est ce qui est sensé à la
porte ce nom alors
qu'en suède et aux degrés glace avec moi
quand tu remets les vidéos de greg et
tout le monde s'est moqué de moi quand
j'ai dit que c'était une étiquette boom
là vous avez fait un arrêt sur image
comme pour maeva vous avez fait un arrêt
sur image et on a interprété une photo
mais si tu remets la vidéo correctement
tu vois qu'il entra je parle pas de ça
je parle de la vie dont il est séparé de
sa ville et du cratère ils ont gratté
avant de parler dans sa gratte énorme
était le bien aller voir il en train de
gratter le truc mais quand tu fais en
arrêt sur image tu as l'impression donc
en vrai les photos d'interprétation tout
ça tu vois jj je te prends donc la
poudre blanche qui était dans son essai
parce qu'il est tombé malade est en ce
moment à part les dix justes mais en
très bon état précise voiture ne
condamnerais jamais quinquin sur une
photo parce que je vois et on a exemple
pour un jour peut être je me sens plus
tu as été sur est traité sur les
tournages cgt sur un tournage des anges
mais on va pas être complètement
hypocrite dans beaucoup de soirées
parisiennes dans la paix remis par des
sur internet reçues circulent pas
pourquoi les jeunes sérénité serait
exemple de ceux de ceux de ce drame qui
circule partout dans tout paris qui
n'ont complètement paris moi je ne
connaissais je dirai évidemment jamais
son nom quelqu'un latéralité qui
participent aux engins moment que j'ai
retrouvée qui était pas où aller parce
qu'on n'était pas dans les anges et dans
un autre une autre émission de télé
réalité et il m'a montré sa chaussure
dans sa chaussure il avait découpé de
talons hauts talons étaient comme comme
malcom un vieux personnages de
télévision ouais les faits une fausse
cachette attention talent il y avait de
la drogue la terre ne sont pas longs cas
où ils soient fouillés quand il rentre
dans la maison
juste passer un autre sujet parce que va
pardon mais du coup tout est dit avec
menace qu veines des jambes n'a pas
exposé et de solutions donc on sa
navette solution n'a pas été
parfait mais là on n'est pas là pour
trouver solution la personne de
peut-être le premier nom c'est un peu ce
qui s'est passé que jamais qu'on avance
sur deux filles aussi parce que moi mais
je n avais parlé il ya deux ans on a
trouvé des solutions parce que c'est
quand même important que ça met en
danger des gens qui vont sur ses
tournages en temps mais je pensais ça
passe à ses producteurs de l'évolution
si je peux même pas l'intention de
remplacer
au producteur de trouver moi ce qui
m'intéresse ici c'est le deuxième sujet
que d une sujet vous dit aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de prostitution dans la télé
réalité c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes filles qui sont dans la télé
rites et qui sont pardon de le dire des
escortes c'est vrai ça oui non ça c'est
pas moi qui ai rarement je pense que
c'est connu depuis assez longtemps
maintenant je pense qu ici on a quand
même pas mal qui le savent qu il y adeux
l'escorting dans la téléréalité mois
encore ces femmes là font ce qu'elles
veulent pour moi ya pas de sou messier
s'ils veulent vendre si elles veulent
être travailleuses du sexe elles font ce
qu'elles veulent ce que je condamne
c'est la production parce que c'est mon
expérience que j'ai eu c'est d'un
producteur qui m'a dit mot pour mot et
je sais que tu sais de qui je parle qui
m'a dit mot pour mot en parlant de la
tête fin d'une des grandes têtes
d'affiché des marseillais
leproux qui sont pas avec ce garçon et
c'est juste tête de trois heures avant
de partir en tournage démarre ses vestes
le reste du monde je lui ai expliqué que
c'est un garçon qui me plaisait pas il
m'a dit mot pour mot c'est dommage il
est gentil et en plus de ça tu
triplerait ton salaire à la sortie de
cette émission ah oui alors et vous vous
appelez ça comment moi j'appelle
moi ce que j'aurais pas v'nu salaires
parce que je vais sortir avec une led
affiche par la suite je serai en télé
en fait il ya deux sujets différents
parlers le braille et le sujet
effectivement des deux ça c'est vrai de
il y en a qui étaient vraiment des
escortes pas pardon aux jeunes si sienne
mais on avait vu décide quand tu faisais
des émissions qui était vraiment des
escortes et qui sont venus faire
l'émission après du coup est-ce qu'elles
sauront elles sont repartis vers
d'escorting voilà ça c'est vrai il ya un
autre sujet qui est différent dans ce
que tu dis qu'ils aient on entre dans la
production et parfois on a envie de se
mettre avec personne il n'y a pas
d'histoire d'amour et là c'est vrai je
reconnais ce parfois on peut te dire ça
serait bien que tu sortes avec untel
parce que du coup on aura une histoire
tu ferais les quotidiennes et du coup
tout à rester plus longtemps dans
l'émission ça c'est une refuse c'est
qu'en fait on est exclu et à partir du
moment l'exclusion commence
l'harcèlement commencé mais non ils
allaient aborder la production et de la
part des candidats rentrent exclu qu'on
n'explique pas c'est juste que une barre
2d et gamarde histoire
chèque ils ne sont qu des petites
histoires d'amour me
copient histoire d'amour pour rester
c'est un souci comme quoi laisser planer
prince william la menchum fait pour
l'amour à temps j'avais joué les mains
question en quoi ces 48 a passé le
casting pour les anges 9 ouais j'avais
passé un casting et tu verras 11 j'avais
raconté que pendant le casting le
producteur fin les casteurs tu avais
posé une question qui était extrêmement
violente extrêmement violente voilà mais
moi ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
pourquoi près cette question rituelle
quand même intégré alors pourquoi vous y
répondre même si pour moi c'est pas trop
mon élection je vous le dis est ce que
tu t'es trop encore et je ne sais pas
mais je vous y répondre j'ai été
extrêmement offusqué après cette
question d'ailleurs joué est sorti et
j'ai refusé de faire cette saison n'a
pas ce que ça devait être les enjeux 10
à ce moment là oui donc j'ai tous les
messages qui le prouvent des recettes
voyages et déposé plainte pour moi tu es
rentré j'ai pu le retrouver
le producteur qui m'a posé cette
question a été viré
coïncidence j'ai ma famille pendant la
saison que j'ai faite il n'était plus là
on investit les aider je veux que ces
animations à terre vous êtes jeune et
vous avez aussi intelligent quel intérêt
d'être ce soir sur le plateau et de
faire tout ça on va lutter c'est
dénoncer quelque chose c'est que ça doit
faire du sport c'est prévenir les jeunes
là les jeunes mecs qui seraient
intéressés par ce projet la scène il ya
des raisons parce que depuis vous avez
dénoncé vous continuez à la télé reste
également arrêter de faire de la télé a
déjà admis que j'arrêtais sa lettre
datant pardon
d'abonnés
masque exclusivement le coup parce que à
la suite de ma première émission de télé
réalité j'ai fait une interview que vous
pourrez retrouver sur youtube j'ai fait
une première émission qui m'a seulement
pas fait rapporté d'argent ni à 22 voilà
exactement j'ai fait mon interview
samedi à angers tous dénoncé donc
quelqu'un qui a envie de refaire à 30
éléments de la télé ne prend pas le
risque de dénoncer et magali fiscaux
question est qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
tu as à répondre à tous à magali
d'habitude et que notre roi tu les
connais par coeur tous ces gens là ces
légères je vais être honnête avec vous
moi je parlais je connais des gens qui
ne sont pas du tout ce que j'entends
après encore une fois je remets pas en
doute ou enfin je sais c'est compliqué
pour moi parce que je n'ai pas la même
vision des choses parce que je vois et
j'entends passe à dire que moi j'ai eu
la gagnes tu connais tous ces gens par
coeur ses eaux d'égout tabac de drogue
y'a pas de score
attention j'ai pas dit ça j'ai jamais
dit il ya vincent shogun tu es venu sur
ce plateau la dernière fois a dit j'ai
ramené en secret de la drogue et il a eu
le courage et l'honnêteté il a rien à
gagner parce qu'il fait plus téléralité
et bravo à lui de dire je les cache et à
la production c'est vrai voilà et l'a
assumé donc bien sûr que quand on veut
quand on est drogué quand on est
dépendant que tu sois en télé réalité ou
non pour tous tu vas essayer de santé
bas et bien sûr que c'est là où le
vigilant bien sûr que les productions
doivent être bien vu alors plus la
drogue sur l'alcool à profusion
maintenant la prostitution moi je suis
désolé je je je vois des jeunes filles
en télé réalité qui sont des filles qui
sont accomplis qui sont affirmés qui se
battent qui qui qui prône le le le si
c'était le cas on voit passants se
réunir et toutes les femmes de la
terreur et lui et on dirait ce garçon ne
me plaît pas et je vais faire opposition
à la production parce que alors peu
importe désigne un là encore jean
millier de tentes en valais respect au
grand palais d'été entend rencontrer des
gens
une fois encore j'ai envie de le ton
soit pas trop hypocrite parce que des
boîtes de production savent très bien
qu'elles engagent tel ou tel travail
actrice comédienne de telle a été enfin
candidate de tnt elle sait très bien que
certaines soient score dès le début
avant même qu à vendre la maison et du
coup elles peuvent pas le dire que le
savent donc comment elles font qu'elle
remplissait les fiches il ya certaines
s'écrie un tel vent 2 intel strip
teaseuse à belle beille et quand elle
son escorte ses écrits mot de passe
dubai dubai escorte sûr que oui
généralement sec sur doit céder je ne
doute pas je me bagarre car c'était
quand c'était avant la basse et n ya pas
très longtemps que le dit moi je
mangeais pas jeter a pas donné les amis
vous pouvez pas rejeter le débat amitié
en danger vous pouvez pas mettre des
gens et moi tu vas parler tout le monde
dans le même panier
des rumeurs et des ailes magané on m'a
dit que mais j'ai dit que magali magail
manioc patates rd non quand même pas
dire appel et inner wheel mans magali
estime que tu dit magali s'est pas ému
j'ai des noms aimé maeght on se
comprenait jeu je ne suis pas en train
de dire que salle camille jamais son
escale jeudi que le mot de passe seydou
bâ lui expliquer quelque chose si tu est
témoin d'un truc comme ça et que tu ne
le dénonce mais bon je vais tomber
facilement 3 gagne suis pas complice
de tout dans ce cas là vous êtes aussi
que je dénonce je n'ai pas vu ça et moi
je suis désolé
quant à l'époque de canal+ et tf1 canal
+ 10 était feinte une boîte à quoi qu'on
ait que cannes tef a répondu vous mettre
une boîte à cons qu'une boîte à cork on
savait tous que tout ce qu'on voyait
canal+ s'en foutent et plein de pistes à
l'époque et on n'a pas dénoncé on n'a
pas de dénoncer ça fait des années -
mais excuse moi moi je vais te dire
quelque chose je n'ai jamais et je le
dis ici et je ne continuerai à le dire
que ça vous plaise ou pas je n'ai jamais
vu un de mes candidats se droguer
d'accord alors peut-être tu en as afin
qu'ils le font derrière mon dos mais
parce que si jamais j'en vois un le
quotidien non c'est parce que c'est
parce qu'on dit c'est parce qu'on du
magasin qui les connaît tous par coeur
s'est bien passé nuit avec pathé journée
avec était l'heure de découvrir que les
escortes et s était candidate au maquis
et boîtes à coke ils sortent tout de
suite
reconnu marc ganis a que ma vie puisque
la laitue et aujourd'hui que ça pas mal
de
comment de poule non tu vas pas mal de
poulain annoncé qu'elle conseille
aujourd'hui que leur donnerait
aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui pour pour
qu'il s'arrête ça ou rester sur comment
tu les conjectures elle dit qu'elle a
une manière mais à l'eau je ne prenne
pas prise explique je ne cautionne pas
trop ce que répond que d'après lui
c'est quelque chose je m en corse mais
quatre conseils qui leur donnerait
aujourd'hui pour nietzsche et les choses
il ils ont ils ont ils ont le droit je
sais plus qui a dit tout à l'heure ils
ont le droit
c'est jean-michel qu'est ce qu'ils ont
le droit comme tout le monde c'est grave
ne faisons pas le droit parce que ce
sont des exemples effectivement et donc
non en fait c'est pourtant d'accord
ce qui
a été dit que l'une de seulement par des
gens qui ont tous les deux dit il
contient reprises devant alors ça que je
te dis je ne remets pas tu as vécu
quelque chose que je n'ai pas vécu donc
généralement afin de trouver des
solutions c'est à dire que dire je n'ai
jamais vu donc je ne sais pas c'est fou
je t'ai dis c'est pas grave je te
demande juste quelque chose m'a guéri
les yeux dans les yeux magali les yeux
dans les yeux sa petite manon les yeux
dans les yeux à moi à moi a dit à moi
parce que c'est important ce qu'elle dit
raison voilà que effectivement depuis un
certain temps il y a des gens qui sort
des tournages et qui disent des choses
d'accord ce qui n'arrivait pas avant
donc évidemment qu'il faut les entendre
et évidemment qu'il faut vous écouter
évidemment la cause il a gagné pour
magali la guérite se désarme ses encours
nom et qui est jeté sur moi dans toutes
les jeunes filles que tu as 2
honnêtement tu n'es pas du tout au
courant que les jeunes filles qui ont
été ou qui sont escorte matin alors moi
je n'étais pas dans le passé au maire de
magali même mongeau sur écoute avec mais
pourquoi tu veux que je te dis mais je
me dis juste une hormone panne on te
demande pas de nom avant je demande pas
de nous et condamné 7 6 pour faire
plaisir et condamné à ce petit événement
ce qu'il ya dedans aller mais je n'en ai
pas dit où la tendresse et la pétition
mais je le juge d'abord je ne juge pas
dit les choses mais quelle mais quand
bien même je ne veux pas me dire dénonce
portes avant et ben je manque pas dire
dénommé tu as l'air de dire bah non dieu
n'a pas l'espace que
doit être puni ou qu'elle doit être ce
qu'on a dit ça magali tu sais ça c'est
bien tu peux dire oui bien effectivement
son sens et devis mais oui mais c'est
pas à moi de juger on ne juge pas j'ai
dit pash au courant de rien enfin vision
tu ne fais cross c'est l'école de la
légion d'honneur mais
pas de réseau non non non c'est trop
facile durable affaire à moi jamais dit
ça c'est pas vrai d'accord jci tu diras
pas des sciences ya pas de jouer moi
personnellement elle a coincé là
tellement d'accord j'ai honteusement pas
si tu en as vu aux demandes si tu sais
qu'ils ont la mémoire différence dois tu
sais pas
je pars pas de rumeurs jetant du beurre
si j'ai pas envie de mettre des gens
d'en bas des gens qui font ce qu'il faut
ce sont des malades non magali on n'est
pas là pour juger on dit la vérité sur
commune écoutez moi je ne je pars d'un
principe et c'est mon éducation je ne
condamnerais personne mais pour qu'on
garde on ne condamne pas mais en vous
disant que j'ai vu au moins vous disant
que je sais c'est que j'ai vu quelque
part tu as well as pas de preuve alors
même voir les matchs mais enfin vous
vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites
mais non mais qu'est ce que je dis moi
les influences allant jeter tout pas
même été un peu d'eau aucune personne
qui prend de la dénommée l'apl a pas vu
complètement les suppositions est ce que
je devrais suppositions il y en a comme
chez les gens qui ont la même envie que
l'on sait c'est qu'il faut trouver c'est
gentil ça surtout j'essaie trouver des
solutions mais pentue
les rues
j'étudie il y à ça je t'écoute et je te
dis il faut faire attention parce que
quand vous touchez
photo null un bref en tous les cas la
tuer voilà on va conclure à tuer mais
effectivement je trouve que c'est pas la
meilleure défense rien sur des rumeurs
et et c'est pas des rumeurs darcos
magali piété mois
hormis moi je vais te dire qu'elle fait
pas de on dit je les veux toi je l' ai
vu je cois normandie de quoi écouter la
personne n'ouvre son talon qui monte
avant que ça on dit ne pas ne veux pas
le mettre dans l'embarras dire qui
s'étonna reste à les juger mais je ne
dis pas que j'ai commis et tu dis pas
c'est une idée rumeurs avec magali
candide et magali comme j'ai des idées
aussi magali magali bébé quand j'étais à
nrj 12 mois par exemple obligé de le
dire il y avait des candidats qui
avaient déjà des sites des sites avec
des tarifs des storting avant qu on les
engage merde à un moment
tu le savais toi c'est de la production
mais je ne juge pas du pacs et mariage
pas jeu juste pas mais ne sait pas en
expliquer c'est que la télé réalité vous
êtes constamment constamment en train de
la diabolisez pas du tout aux couleurs
des formes actuelles amis je suis le
premier à me fondre inapte à bord elle
est là c'est la réalité les jeunes après
ça donc tous les candidats - y compris
et tous les autres une fois qu'on le
sort de ces programmes on est jetés dans
la foire aux lions sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le si bercy sur ces très la
pression de l'après tournage la
diffusion des épisodes tout ça c'est
énorme et crédit en plus de ça
bizarrement point commun à tous les
castings on est tous très jeunes et tous
avaient des situations avec sequans
ghanéen
qui gagnent à plat qui ne gagne pas
beaucoup d'argent et surtout il n'y a
aucun suivi psychologique tournage avait
gelé vue moi j'ai vu des gens souffrir
sur un tournage et ça m'a fait de la
peine je me suis dit cette pauvre cette
pauvre fille elle va rentrer chez elle
c'est ton expérience et je remets à
kader imelhaine je ne vais pas contre ce
que tu dis je l'entends c'est une
expérience que moi je ne connais pas je
n'ai par nature
dans les marseillais par exemple par
exemple tu vois je sais que un moment
donné il y avait un candidat qui était
pas bien la productrice lui a envoyé le
psy immédiatement hors tournage et ça
pour moi c'est ce que j'ai vu donc c'est
ce que je peux témoigner aussi donc on a
des histoires différentes que j'entends
j'entends la tienne j'entends amin on va
dans le même sens parce que ce qu'on
veut c'est remis que devenu trop
politique devient trop politique
ressemble peut-être interviewé hidalgo
et toi tu es devenu hyper ronde
mais là où je rejoins un sourire des
gens qui disent qu'ils ont vu des choses
il faut mon attention ya pas d accord
ludivine et puis après la mode chacune
pour conclure mais en bienveillance je
pense que c'est pas que faire attention
mais je vous crois mademoiselle je pense
pas que vous ayez les airs alignement
sur des plateaux télé pour aller
déverser des comme ça bien sûr
maintenant eries que nathaniel veut des
solutions et vu le poids que tu as mag
aujourd'hui par rapport à q2 la
production que ce n'est parce que ce ne
serait pas justement bien de tapas de de
convoquer chez nos oreilles tu vas tu
vas être que tu vas être unis des
réseaux sociaux en ligne avec ça je vais
je vais t'en formé quelque chose et on
l'a pas dit médiatiquement mais je vais
te dire ce soir quand j'ai eu un débat
ici avec la ministre elisabeth mort et
neuf sur la place des femmes dans la
téléralité etc on a organisé l émoi une
réunion à vienne trois semaines après
dans ses bureaux en soit on en a
beaucoup parlé en twin on n'en sait pas
seulement
les producteurs de toutes les
productions ça veut dire qu'il y avait
au je vais pas citer leurs noms mais
yahvé on s'est tu les connais les
productions qui ont et qu'ils ont été
vus par parole elisabeth moreno et qui a
décidé d'organiser des choses avec ils
sont venus la voir pour m et donc les
conclusions devaient donc sa masse est
pas mettre en place des choses il faut
virer ces personnes là parce qu'elle
soit extrêmement dangereuse cette
personne là qui me dit clairement un
métier me demande si on n'agit gt oui on
a organisé l 2 contre les mêmes
habitudes pascal couillaud c'est qu'ils
allaient agir en angola theresa may
incroyable
ces deux solistes une image vraie raison
c'est une divine m'a demandé si
aujourd'hui avec ce que je faisais
j'avais fait des choses donc je te
réponds je lui réponds oui on a organisé
une réunion avec la ministre dont une
égalité homme femme ouais convoqué les
produits que j'ai compris donc vous avez
si on veut que les producteurs c'est
fini ça vous dérange pas la seule chose
que je vous dis moi si tu seras galy
magazine que ces normes et recettes de
travailler moi ce que tu dis moi
seulement c'est très bien tout ce que tu
dis mais effectivement les anges s'est
terminée là où il ya des coeurs brisés
ça s'arrête ça dit aussi bah non c'est
parce que je te dise baba je te dis pas
l'essentiel at il hérité ça marche plus
fx a été vendu pas pardon je te dire de
la télé-réalité c'est simplement gentil
et les décisions sont prises au moment
où ça n'existe plus c'est rejeter sa
maman bien même tu veux je te dis c'est
pas grave tu sais pourquoi non à ce que
ça fait
savoir dire